SIERRA: So I’ve always been curious.
What happens when you don’t finish a whole
pack of antibiotics because sometimes you
feel better halfway through, and they tell
you to take 12, and you’re like, 12?
That’s way too much.
I’m all set with six.
TALKINGTON: Right.
The challenge is if you take a more limited
number then there’s the potential that you
kill off some of the bad bacteria that’s
being targeted, but some of it survives.
And the bacteria that survives, and the bacteria
that survives then has the opportunity to
learn how to defeat that antibiotic that has
been prescribed.
SIERRA: So don’t save the other six and
give it to my friend without health insurance.
TALKINGTON: No, please don’t.
Please don’t do that.
SIERRA: Noted.
Never will!
Antibiotics are one of the most important
discoveries in history, and they can seem
like a magical cure-all.
We take them for granted, and we expect them
to fix everything from infected cuts to strep
throat.
But bacteria are learning to outsmart antibiotics
on a massive scale.
Hundreds of thousands are dying every year,
and that number could soon rise into the millions.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, what happens when bacteria in our body
become resistant to antibiotics.
And a curable infection suddenly becomes … incurable.
CBS THIS MORNING: This morning, new details
on how our food supply is giving rise to antibiotic
resistance superbugs.
AL JAZEERA: An invisible but deadly threat
has creeped into U.S. hospitals.
BBC NEWS: It will spread quickly … and the
chances that it will spread globally are very
high..
SIERRA: You may have heard about this before
on TV or in the news.
Or this may be your first time.
Either way, antibiotic resistance can be super
confusing.
I know it was for me.
So before we dig into it, let’s get the
basics straight.
Antibiotic resistance doesn’t mean your
body becomes resistant to antibiotics.
Bacteria do.
When you’re sick and you take antibiotics,
most of the bacteria get wiped out.
Bam, gone, no more sick days, back to work.
But some bacteria can be really crafty.
They fight off the antibiotic and survive.
There aren’t enough left to make you feel
sick, but once they reproduce, they can turn
into a resistant strain that endangers other
people.
This has a chance of happening any time antibiotics
are used.
The more we misuse them, the stronger the
bacteria become.
But in order to understand what a big deal
this is, we probably need to take a trip back
in time.
So what was life like before antibiotics?
TALKINGTON: The reality before antibiotics
were available was that people could die from
a simple cut.
SIERRA: This is Kathy Talkington.
She directs the project on antibiotic resistance
at the Pew Charitable Trusts.
Her work is the gold standard in the field.
She spoke to us from Pew’s studio in DC.
TALKINGTON: About a third of the deaths pre-antibiotics
were due to infections, in the United States.
And, you know, when you think about things
like childbirth, a lot of folks were dying
from that without the advancement of antibiotics.
So things that we very much take for granted
today back then were just a whole different
reality when they were scared of some basic
infections.
SIERRA: Life was a lot more risky.
TALKINGTON: It was.
SIERRA: Bacteria.
Microscopic organisms.
We can’t see them with our naked eye but
they’re literally everywhere.
They were the first lifeform on earth, and
they have helped us breathe, eat, and grow
into the species we are today.
If bacteria disappeared overnight, then every
lifeform on the planet would vanish in a matter
of years.
But there’s a flip side; some bacteria are
harmful, and they lead to conditions ranging
from an infected cut on your finger to diseases
like tuberculosis and the plague; diseases
that have claimed millions upon millions of
lives throughout history.
TALKINGTON: Antibiotics have often been referred
to as a miracle drug.
And the way they work is they kill off the
bacteria by either just killing it or reducing
its ability to reproduce.
Back in 1928, Alexander Fleming is given credit
for finding penicillin, and he was working
in his lab, looking at bacteria, and sort
of by happenstance, when he came back after
being out for a few days, saw that there was
mold growing in the petri dish, and what he
noticed is the bacteria next to that mold
had died off and what’s interesting is when
he discovered penicillin, and he fully understood
how antibiotics worked, he warned everybody
that we have to use these cautiously, that
resistance will develop.
FLEMMING: And I have a fear that when penicillin
can be bought over the counter patients will
indulge in over medication, and in many cases
they will not take large enough doses, if
the dose is too small the microbes will not
cured and they will be educated to resist
penicillin.
TALKINGTON: And unfortunately, we didn’t
heed that advice as we should have, we had
sort of a heyday or the golden age of antibiotic
discovery where we were staying ahead of the
resistance of antibiotics of bacteria.
Unfortunately, that didn’t last...Because
we have not come up with new what they often
call classes of antibiotics, the bacteria
are outsmarting us.
They’ve defeated or have figured out, in
many cases, how to defeat the drugs that we
have available.
SIERRA: In fact, the world hasn’t come up
with a new “class” of antibiotics since
the early 1980s.
Think of it this way, the last time we struck
a major blow against bacteria, shoulder pads
were in, Russia was still the Soviet Union,
and Blondie was on top of the charts.
For more than 40 years, bacteria have been
gaining ground in our race against resistance.
SIERRA: Why can’t we just keep making new
and better antibiotics?
TALKINGTON: We currently do not have, enough
pharmaceutical companies investing in research
and development around antibiotics, because
the return is not there.
When you think about a company trying to decide,
all right, am I going to make a new antibiotic?
I know it’s going to cost a lot of money
to figure this out and get it through the
pipeline and get it to the patient’s bedside.
And I know that once I get it across there,
I’m not going to be able to sell it very
often because we don’t want to use it.
And then you compare that to something like
a chronic disease drug, where the minute it’s
available and it’s better than the most
recent one, the sales are going to be higher,
the price potentially is higher, and it’ll
be used for maybe a lifetime of that patient.
So the calculation is very different compared
to other opportunities.
SIERRA: Right.
Money talks.
Demand talks.
TALKINGTON: Right.
SIERRA: Drugs that patients will take every
day for the rest of their lives can earn a
lot of money.
Take the arthritis drug, Humira, which registered
19.9 billion dollars in global sales in 2018.
Antibiotics just can’t compete with those
numbers.
And so there’s not a strong financial reason
to develop them.
But let’s say things change in the United
States or Europe.
Maybe governments offer big financial incentives
that encourage drugmakers to really dive into
antibiotioc research.
There’s every chance that there might be
a breakthrough leading to new, specialized
antibiotics.
But that alone wouldn’t solve the problem.
And that’s because bacteria are developing
new and different resistances all over the
world, and bacteria like to travel.
For example, take the resistant enzyme NDM-1,
which is present in several types of bacteria.
ITN News: We’ve all heard of E.coli, but
scientists have found a new bug that can live
inside this and it’s resistant to almost
all antibiotics.
A new gene NDM-1 has reached the U.K. and
scientists warn it could spread rapidly, as
nothing is being developed to treat it.
SIERRA: NDM-1 was first observed in Sweden
in the mid-2000s.
But within just a few years, it had cropped
up in over 80 countries.
This is just one example of how quickly resistant
bacteria can spread.
TALKINGTON: This is very much an international
issue.
This is the issue is that resistance knows
no borders.
SIERRA: So we can’t just solve the problem
at home wherever home may be and be safe.
TALKINGTON: Exactly.
I should say, however, it’s important for
every country to do what they can.
We shouldn’t wait for, say, a global solution
to this problem.
While that would be the ideal, in the meantime,
everything that each country is doing to address
this will help.
But we do need to think about this and look
at this at a global level.
SIERRA: So how is it different, let’s say,
here in the United States versus somewhere
like China or India?
TALKINGTON: There are different challenges
that each is facing.
For example, in China and India, some of the
issues around antibiotics are they may have
them available over the counter for human
use, which we don’t have in the United States,
so how do they begin to address that and making
sure that those antibiotics are getting to
the appropriate people.
But they’re having to weigh that reality
with the fact that many people are dying from
infections that could be treated with antibiotics,
so there’s an access problem for some of
these drugs versus the potential excess use
of antibiotics.
SIERRA: When thinking about a problem this
big, it’s easy to lose sight of the people
who have to deal with it every day.
The patients who are suffering, and the doctors
who are struggling to treat them.
And if you lose sight of this, you kind of
lose sight of the human toll.
It seemed like it was time to call a doctor.
SATLIN: My name's Michael Satlin.
I'm a physician at Weill Cornell medicine
and I see patients at New York Presbyterian
Hospital in New York City and my research
focuses on better understanding the epidemiology
of resistant bacteria and trying to come up
with strategies that might help deal with
how we prescribe antibiotics and manage patients.
When somebody presents with a urinary tract
infection we should be able to just treat
that quickly with pills that you can pick
up at your pharmacy.
But because of resistance a lot of times there
are no pills that are available to treat that
infection.
So they have to come to the emergency room.
They have to have a procedure where they have
a venous catheter put into their arm.
They have to arrange for antibiotics to be
infused at home or sometimes they can't do
that.
They have to go to a rehab to have that done
or stay hospitalized.
There are complications from having it.
So I think for every one case where there
is some tragic outcome because of resistance
there are probably 10 cases like that.
TALKINGTON: So bacteria are evolving just
as humans evolved.
They have ways of adapting that defeat the
drugs that we’ve created.
When we use antibiotics in any setting whether
it’s in human setting, medical care, or
in farming it contributes to the development
of antibiotic resistance.
So in the United States, for example, we’re
using about 70 percent of the antibiotics
in animal agriculture.
SIERRA: So we haven’t even mentioned the
other massive part of resistance.
Even if every single person on earth took
antibiotics correctly, and that’s a big
if, we’d still have a huge problem.
And that’s because we are not the only ones
who consume these medications.
Frontline: And by using antibiotics in food/animal
production we’re creating drug resistant
pathogens that can then go on to cause drug
resistant infections.
When you put the animals together and have
them confined its alot easier to pass diseases
back in forth, giving them a little bit of
antibiotics seemed to fix that problem, sort
of put a bandaid over it.
I am looking at trying to prevent any health
issues in this small city of chickens of 100
thousand.
SIERRA: Giving antibiotics to animals is common
worldwide, but the question of the right way
to do it is controversial.
TALKINGTON: One of the things that we need
to do in animal agriculture is we need to
implement stewardship principles, and what
I mean by that is we need to have programs
on the farm that drive appropriate use of
antibiotics, to make sure that we’re using
the antibiotics only when necessary.
SIERRA: So if I’m a farmer and I’m using
antibiotics on my herd, am I using it because
my cow is sick, or am I giving it to all of
my cows so that none of them get sick?
TALKINGTON: So it depends.
One area that they’ve been used and are
no longer allowed in the United States but
sometimes used in other parts of the world,
and that’s for growth promotion, it helps
to make the animal grow faster.
SIERRA: So it has nothing to do with sickness.
It’s just getting a plump chicken?
TALKINGTON: Exactly.
Exactly, in a shorter amount of time.
So that’s one category.
The second category is basically preventing
the disease.
Where you might have a situation where you
know in these circumstances often disease
crops up.
So you’re going to give an antibiotic in
order to prevent that from happening.
And sometimes it’s called prevention and
control.
A control example would be when you might
have one animal that’s sick in the herd,
and you treat the rest of them to prevent
the spread.
And then the ultimate area is for treatment
when you have a sick animal with a clear indication
of bacterial infection, then antibiotics can
be used for that.
SIERRA: So, why does this matter?
Well, because when animals develop resistant
bacteria, it can spread to us.
And there are a lot of ways.
It can reach us through the meat we eat or
when we come into contact with animals.
And if you are close enough to an infected
animal, it can even reach us through the air
we breathe.
Resistant bacteria can even get into the water
farmers use to irrigate their crops.
TALKINGTON: The resistant bacteria gets into
that water.
The water may be then used to irrigate your
crops of lettuce, and someone could then eat
the lettuce that has the resistant bacteria.
And there are many other more complex ways
that that resistant bacteria can be shared
in many different facets before it gets to
a human, maybe in a hospital, et cetera.
The pathway can be complicated, but the science
has been clear that there is a relationship.
SIERRA: So even being a vegetarian is not
going to help me defeat this?
TALKINGTON: Exactly right.
SIERRA: I have to stop drinking water, stop
eating lettuce, stop petting pigs.
I mean, what can I do?
TALKINGTON: Right.
Or we can stop using antibiotics unnecessarily
and reducing the incidence.
SIERRA: So what are we doing wrong?
TALKINGTON: So the unnecessary use of antibiotics
is accelerating the development of antibiotic
resistance.
For example, the World Health Organization
estimates that about 50 percent of the antibiotics
being prescribed are unnecessary.
SIERRA: Oh, wow.
TALKINGTON: And, again, the more we use antibiotics,
no matter what setting whether it’s in the
human setting or in animal setting we’re
driving resistance, we’re expediting the
development of resistance.
SATLIN: I had a patient, a young woman with
lymphoma who was undergoing a stem cell transplant.
The hope was with this transplant her lymphoma
would be cured and she could lead a long life
and everything was going OK until one morning
while her immune system was weak from chemotherapy
and we were waiting for her immune system
to recover, she told her nurse around 9:00
in the morning that she was short of breath
and by that afternoon her organs essentially
stopped working.
She had a fever, she had to be put on a breathing
machine, she needed medicines to keep her
blood pressure up, at our first sign of fever
we did get blood cultures and we started her
on what we thought were appropriate antibiotics
for the types of infections that we typically
see.
But unfortunately by the next day she died
and a day after that we actually figured out
what she had, what she was infected with and
she was infected with a bacteria that was
resistant to all the antibiotics that we had
given her.
TALKINGTON: The most recent statistics we
have from the Centers for Disease Control
is about 23,000 people a year in the United
States are dying from resistant infections.
And I think the number globally is about 700,000
according to the World Health Association.
TALKINGTON: And, those are older numbers.
The Centers for Disease Control is expected
to update that.
So I think, unfortunately, we’ll see those
numbers going up.
SIERRA: Since I spoke with Kathy, the Centers
for Disease Control did in fact release new
figures.
They found that 2.8 million resistant infections
occur in the United States each year, and
that the number of annual deaths had risen
to 35,000.
SATLIN: There have been some estimates that
have been made, that if we continue our current
track by 2050 there'll be 10 million people
a year who die from antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
I know it's hard to know.
That's a modeling figure.
But I do think that in our current state if
we follow our current track that the problems
of antibiotic resistance will just become
more common they'll become more frequent.
SIERRA: Why do you think these numbers aren’t
more well-known?
TALKINGTON: I think the issue of antibiotic
resistance is a complex one for your average
person to fully comprehend.
It’s a lot easier to understand cancer,
and you see the number of people that are
directly affected by that.
You have an advocacy group of people with
these specific diseases.
The challenge with antibiotic resistance is
it’s underlying so many of these.
It doesn’t always rise to the top, to people’s
awareness of the reason for illness or death.
SIERRA: It sounds like it needs a good celebrity
spokesperson to get out there and explain
everything.
TALKINGTON: Possibly, yeah.
SIERRA: What are some of the most important
changes that you would like to see?
TALKINGTON: We want to address this issue
from two basic areas: one is on stewardship.
We have to figure out how to provide incentives,
both in animal agriculture and in human medicine
in the United States and around the globe
to ensure that we’re using these antibiotics
only when they are necessary.
We need to preserve these life-saving drugs
so that when we do need them, they work.
At the same time, we have to put focus on
the innovation of new therapies.
We have to figure out a way to provide incentives
for industry or create some mechanism that
we ensure we have antibiotics to treat the
issues we have now and those that we will
have in the years to come.
SIERRA: So it sounds like a lot of influence
and power rests in the hands of government,
of drug developers and scientists, and of
farmers.
What can we do?
TALKINGTON: What we can do as individuals
is, when we go to the doctor, have that important
conversation about do I have a bacterial infection?
Is an antibiotic the best treatment?
Don’t demand an antibiotic if you have a
viral infection like a cold.
There are things we can do in terms of making
sure when we are eating meat that we cook
it properly and wash our hands, but also becoming
aware of which companies, for example, are
trying to make sure that the proteins that
they are buying are raised responsibly.
We have to get the attention of those that
can make these important decisions about the
allocation of resources.
We need money for research and development.
We need to figure out how to get these innovations
to the patient bedside.
SIERRA: So it sounds like we just have to
be better educated, ask better questions,
and take Vitamin C instead of an antibiotic.
TALKINGTON: Wash your hands.
SIERRA: And wash our hands!
Flemming: It is only five years since penicillin
was available to the public.
And in that short time, penicillin and other
antibiotics have made it necessary to rewrite
all the textbooks of medical treatment.
Things have moved very rapidly.
They are still moving very rapidly and before
another five years have passed.
There will be other new antibiotics, which
will extend the scope and bring other infections
under control.
When penicillin first came to light neither
I nor anyone else had the slightest conception
of the enormous influence that it and the
later antibiotics would have on medical practice.
SIERRA: There is a lot more to learn about
antibiotic resistance, more than we could
cover in our short window.
So visit us at CFR.org/whyitmatters where
you can find a page for this episode that
includes all kinds of things!
Including a healthy dose of show notes, a
transcript, and links to great articles and
other resources!
Subscribe to Why It Matters!
Doctors orders!
You can do it on Apple Podcasts, or Spotify,
or Stitcher or wherever you get your audio.
And to ensure the continued health of our
podcast leave us a review, and give us some
stars and them your friends and family!
Of course, we want to hear from you directly
too.
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and the Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
This episode was copiously researched by Menyae
Christopher and me, Rafaela Siewert.
Original music was composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Rafaela Siewert,
signing off.
See ya next time!